les élus locaux à l'occasion d'un
indispensable
retour d'expérience qui sera riche
d'enseignements je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée en charge des
collectivités territoriales madame
caroline cayeux eu la parole madame la
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur pascal martin je veux tout
d'abord apporté au nom du gouvernement
tout mon soutien à nos concitoyens dont
les vies sont bouleversés par ces
incendies exceptionnel je veux aussi
saluer et rendre hommage à l'engagement
des acteurs de la sécurité civile dans
des conditions d'une extrême difficulté
parfois au péril de leur vie pour
protéger les populations et les
territoires de l'avancée du feu vos
questions monsieur le sénateur se
rapporte à notre modèle de sécurité
civile dont je sais que vous êtes un
parfait connaisseur la solidarité
nationale que vous appelez de vos voeux
est déjà à l'oeuvre en gironde les
moyens en renforts nationaux sont
actuellement de plus de 1200 personnel
trois détachements à pied huit colonnes
feux de forêt deux groupes urbains une
colonne lourdes feux de forêt est un
groupe d'appui tactique cette solidarité
nationale est essentiel dans une telle
crise moi aussi je veux saluer le rôle
des élus locaux que j'ai eu
personnellement et individuellement au
téléphone hier et avant-hier il est
essentiel et je tiens à les en remercier
départements et communes sont des
acteurs majeurs de notre modèle de
sécurité civile et de lutte contre les
incendies monsieur le sénateur les
réflexions que vous conduisez seront
utiles pour penser les lendemains de
cette crise par l'ensemble des acteurs à
nouveau soyez assurés de la mobilisation
du gouvernement avec l'ensemble des
forces impliquées dans cette crise
merci souvent la parole notre collègue
jeremy bâti pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologie vous avez
la parole monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues la
sécheresse que nous subissons et le
combustible idéal pour les feux de forêt
après l incendie de la montagne est dans
les bouches-du-rhône celui des monts
d'arrée du jamais vu dans le finistère
c'est aujourd'hui malheureusement là j
qui brûlent les pompiers qu'ils soient
professionnels ou volontaires sapeurs
ont marre et que je tiens ici à saluer
font face à ces feux avec beaucoup de
courage une pensée aussi pour les
populations qui pour certaines ont perdu
beaucoup dans les flammes l'engagement
des communistes que nous sommes en la
matière n'est pas nouveau en prenant la
parole aujourd'hui je m'inscris dans la
suite du travail réalisé en son temps
par mon prédécesseur louis minetti
travail qui avait d'ailleurs abouti à
une loi portant son nom en 1991 les
besoins aujourd'hui nécessite une
gestion publique des forêts fondée sur
l'intérêt général des populations et des
générations futures à l'opposé des choix
qui sont fermes l'affaiblissant
l'émission de louer nef qui voit ses
effectifs amputés par exemple chez moi
en provence outre la sécheresse
estivales et réchauffement climatique
l'une des principales causes des feux de
forêt l'absence de gestion durable de
celle ci le pastoralisme était autrefois
un moyen efficace de nettoyer les bois
pour réduire les risques de départs de
feu pour chaque région des réflexions
concernés concertée avec l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés doivent être engagés
pour trouver des solutions adaptées aux
spécificités de chaque territoire des
régions qui n'étaient pas menacés
auparavant sont aujourd'hui affectés par
la sécheresse hier encore nous pouvions
déplacer des moyens humains et matériels
d'un département à l'autre
aujourd'hui cela n'est plus possible
tant le risque d'incendié est grandement
des départements jusque là épargnés par
les flammes madame la ministre les
quantités de canadairs et autres engins
de lutte doivent elles restées les mêmes
aujourd'hui qu'hier les 5000 pompiers
n'ont vacciné suspendus de leurs
fonctions ne montrent ils pas pour
lutter contre les incendies face à ces
nouvelles réalités et puisque nous
sommes en guerre contre le feu seriez
vous disposé à créer une véritable
cellule de crise transpartisane visant à
mettre en place un plan de lutte
adéquates associant l'ensemble des
acteurs comme notamment la filière bois
ou encore les communes et tenant compte
des spécificités de chaque territoire je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole et
madame bérengère couillard secrétaire
d'état chargée de l'écologie n'avait la
parole merci merci monsieur le merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bachy tout d'abord je souhaite
au nom du gouvernement renouvelé mon
soutien à nos sapeurs pompiers qui
luttent actuellement contre le feu et
ainsi qu'à tous les riverains qui
subissent les conséquences le puriste
dans la république sera à leurs côtés
dès cet après-midi à chaque incendie
c'est tout un écosystème forestier qui
est dévasté une biodiversité qui est
menacée et un puits de carbone qui est
anéanti la prévention qui est
essentielle a montré son efficacité ces
trente dernières années avec une
réduction constante des surfaces
incendiés aujourd'hui le réchauffement
climatique change la donne et nous
devront intensifier les outils et moyens
mis en oeuvre dans les régions sud et
les étendre à l'ensemble du territoire
je pense notamment aux 200 plans de
prévention des risques incendies de
forêt je pense également à la politique
de défense de la forêt contre les
incendies du ministère de l'agriculture
dans cette perspective les obligations
légales de débroussaillement ce sont un
maillon essentiel mais ne se sont pas
appliquées par tous comme elle le
devrait et on le constate notamment sur
le feu de la teste en gironde c'est
pourquoi en mars 2022 nous avons lancé
deux missions d'inspection pour
actualiser la prévention des incendies
et rendre plus contraignantes et plus
efficace les obligations
par ailleurs si le changement climatique
accroît les risques d'incendié je me
dois de rappeler que 90 % des incendies
sont d'origine humaine soit par
imprudence soit par malveillance ils
pourraient être évités en ayant les bons
réflexes au quotidien et un comportement
responsable c'est pour cela que le
gouvernement a lancé une nouvelle
campagne de sensibilisation en juin 2022
avec l'eau nf est également avec météo
france la protection de nos forêts nous
concerne tous
la parole est à notre collègue nicole
duranton pour le groupe du rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendant vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
comme chaque année la tante du jeune
comme de leur famille est grande autour
de parcours sup une attente qui peut
susciter une forme d'inquiétude en effet
cette teinte forme permet aux bacheliers
de décider de leur avenir dans les
études supérieures
les lycéens sont invités à formuler
jusqu'à 30 candidatures sans les classes
et une commission d'examen est ensuite
désigné dans chaque unité de formation
et de recherche il n'y a pas pour le
moment d'algorithmes de sélection unique
la cour des comptes proposée en 2020 de
rendre publics les algorithmes locaux
les lycéens sont invités à accepter ou
décliner chaque oeuvre sous quatre jours
ce qu'ils libèrent des places pour
d'autres ils doivent donc rester
vigilant tout au long de la procédure à
partir du jeudi 2 juin les lycéens ont
reçu leur première réponse le 23 juin
ils ont pu ainsi formulé jusqu'à dix
nouveaux veut certains ont attendu
jusqu'au 15 juillet pour connaître leur
affectation aux dernières nouvelles 86 %
des élèves de terminale et 71 6 % des
étudiants en réorientation avait reçu
une réponse c'est bien mieux qu'en 2021
mais on ne peut pas laisser de côté les
94 1187 candidats qui n'avaient encore
rien reçu ils ont eu l'occasion de
hiérarchiser leurs voeux entre le 15 et
le 18 juillet lundi était donc le
dernier jour de cette procédure
complémentaire depuis les recteurs se
sont mobilisés sur les dossiers restants
même si beaucoup de lycéens sont
frustrés cent mille places environ
demeure pourtant vacantes dans 6000
formation toutefois il convient de
mitiger les constats alarmistes le
nombre d'élèves qui arrêtent leurs
études après le bac n'a pas augmenté
depuis parcours sup depuis dix mille
2018 sans être encore parfaite la plate
forme s'améliore au profit de nos jeunes
et de leur réussite dans l'enseignement
supérieur madame la ministre
la phase deux parcours sub c'est terminé
à quelques jours pouvez vous nous
présenter le bilan que vous en avez fait
nous dire comment les rectorats vont
accompagner les candidats qui n'ont pas
encore encore eu de proposition et
quelles améliorations vous envisagez
apporter pour l'an prochain je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est à m sylvie retailleau ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche le ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice madame duranton donc
effectivement aujourd'hui parcours sup
donc qui existe depuis cinq ans et donc
nous sommes dans une amélioration
continue pour justement tirer parti de
ce retour d'expérience de parcours tueur
depuis cinq ans alors l'objectif c'est
de ne pas laisser d'étudiants d'élèves
au bord du chemin clairement et pour ça
il faut effectivement faire cette
amélioration continue et je vais vous en
présenter quelques pistes je voudrais
d'abord dire que parcours sub ce n'est
pas qu'une plateforme ce n'est pas qu'un
outil parcours sup c'est aussi un
processus avec un accompagnement humain
dans lequel énormément de collègues des
milliers de collègues accompagne en lice
et accompagne dans les établissements et
en rectorat tous nos élèves et je
voudrais vraiment ici en profiter pour
les remercier de leur travail et de leur
engagement sur tout le process de
parcours sup les le bilan alors tout à
fait au 15 juillet vous avez la fin de
la phase principale mais juste pour
préciser la phase complémentaire
continue jusqu'en septembre avec les
rectorats mais aussi avec tout le
process parcours sud jusqu'en septembre
au 15 juillet vous aviez neuf étudiants
sur dix qui ont eu au moins une
proposition au niveau lycée 95 5% au
niveau des bacs généraux et même au
niveau des réorientations nous avions
79% qu'il y avait au moins une
proposition c'est à dire plus de points
par rapport à 2021 je voudrais juste
vous signaler aussi l'impact sur la
réussite des étudiants parce qu'il faut
rentrer mais il faut réussir et c'est là
où on veut emmener nos étudiants
l'impact c'est qu'en deux entre 2018 et
2020 le taux de réussite en premier
cycle et en licence est passé de 40 à 45
% et le taux de boursiers de 20 à 25% il
faut encore continuer bien évidemment
nous sommes dans la phase complémentaire
et depuis le 1er juillet tous les
lycéens ont été appelés au téléphone
pour les inciter à rentrer dans la
commission d'accès à l'enseignement
supérieur où les rectorats comme vous
l'avez dit prennent le relais les pistes
d'amélioration sont nombreuses avec
l'éducation nationale
nous allons améliorer l'information des
débouchés de l'insertion professionnelle
et rajouter à la note de bach dans le
dossier pour plus d'objectivité
voilà je vous remercie merci
la parole est à notre collègue hervé
gillé pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et a évolué
merci monsieur le président madame la
première mini ce monsieur milices de
l'intérieur mes chers collègues notre
maison brûle sous nos yeux vingt mille
600 hectares de brûler 36000 personnes
évacuées la crise climatique en gironde
provoque un drame humain économique
environnemental depuis huit jours deux
feux qualifiés de hors norme à la teste
de buch à landiras ravage notre
département et avancent vers le massif
landais j'aimerais rendre hommage aux
membres des 10 de l'adf pays ainsi qu'à
tous les invisibles de cette crise qui
lutte quotidiennement sur le terrain pas
de victime à déplorer dans ce contexte
c'est remarquable je voudrais également
remercier le président du sénat pour sa
visité le temps nécessaire qu'il a
consacré à écouter l'ensemble des
acteurs et plus particulièrement les
élus locaux
dans ces moments là des visites éclair
ministériels sont particulièrement
contre-productive la gironde constitue
le plus grand massif résineux en europe
et pourtant notre département ne dispose
d'aucun canadair à demeure en provenance
de nîmes ils sont arrivés plus de 12
heures après le début de l'incendié
autrefois il était à mérignac nous le
savons tous chaque minute de gagner est
primordial propriété de l'état leur
maintenance a été délégué un prestataire
privé seulement quatre avions dash sur 6
9 canadairs sur douze sont en mesure de
voler les deux tiers ont plus de 25 ans
nous luttons contre la crise climatique
avec des moyens du siècle passé monsieur
le ministre comptez vous renforcer la
flotte européenne et nationale
relocalisé au moins deux canadairs dans
le sud ouest comptez vous contribuez à
la création d'un secrétariat d'état au
risque civile et crise majeure
pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame sonia backès
secrétaire d'état en charge de la
citoyenneté vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur gillet
oui monsieur le sénateur nous vivons
tous actuellement au rythme à des
incendies qui ravagent notre territoire
et je vous c'est particulièrement
sensible par les feux qui touchent votre
territoire permettez-moi d'abord de
m'associer à l'hommage que vous avez
rendu et aux différents hommages qui ont
été rendus à nos pompiers mobilisés mais
également il ne faut pas les oublier aux
militaires aux élus aux gendarmes aux
policiers qui sont très largement
mobilisés sur ces feux de forêt depuis
le 12 juillet dernier chacun se sent
concerné par ces événements maintenant
je tiens à dire que l'engagement du
gouvernement dans dans ce dossier est
total puisque nous avons engagé la plus
grande la plus grande la plus grande
flotte européenne en matière de lutte
contre les feux 21 avions sont
actuellement mobilisées 12 canadair si
dash 3 beach qui sont aujourd'hui
mobilisés sur ces feux ce déploiement
sans précédent n'a été possible que
parce que nous avons augmenté ces cinq
dernières années le budget de la
sécurité civile de plus de 44%
l'ensemble des moyens prévus dans le
cadre de l'ordre national d'opération
des feux de forêt est engagé et monsieur
le sénateur l'heure n'est pas
aujourd'hui à la polémique mais à la
solidarité et c'est tout le sens
c'est tout le sens du du déplacement du
président de la république aux côtés des
personnes mobilisées sur ces feux de
forêt aujourd'hui
la difficulté nul ne l'ignorent
la difficulté d'une ligne or c'est ce
feu particulièrement important qui sévit
en gironde et c'est l'objet de votre
question monsieur le sénateur le dernier
grand feu que nous avons connue en
gironde avait touché 700 hectares
aujourd'hui c'est plus de 20 mille
hectares qui sont touchés par ces feux
de forêt c'est la raison pour laquelle
des moyens militaires sans précédent ont
été exceptionnellement sollicité
afin de pouvoir mobiliser et accompagner
les forces déjà engagés dans l'est dans
les actions de lutte mais également pour
assurer la surveillance et la détection
des reprises de feu
le ministre gérald a maintenant la
rappeler nous sommes aux côtés des
personnes pour les déplacés pour sauver
des animaux sauver des entreprises et
notre priorité c'est la sécurité des
français pour qu aucune vie ne soit
prise par ces feux merci monsieur gillet
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je comprends bien qu'il ya une
volonté de donner une parole
interministériel par les différentes
justement prise de parole mais pour tout
vous dire concernant cet événement ce
drame
j'aurais presque souhaitait une réponse
de la première ministre
pour l'été pour l'été 2023 il nous faut
une nouvelle loi de programmation sur ce
sujet quoi qu'il en coûte nous vous
attendons toutes les populations qui
sont brisées aujourd'hui à tant de vos
propositions
la parole est à notre collègue guillaume
font-elles pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
monsieur le président madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires la semaine dernière en
réponse à madame la présidente françoise
gatel qui vous interrogeait pertinemment
sur la colère provoquée par la rédaction
des décrets d'application de l'objectif
zéro artificialisation net vous avez
évoqué un manque de pédagogie et
d'accompagnement vis-à-vis vis-à-vis des
élus locaux au delà de la formule
quelque peu paternaliste à l'égard des
mères et de leurs conseillers municipaux
nous nous en tiendrons pas rigueur si
l'enjeu n'était pas de taille en effet
il en va de l'avenir de nos territoires
et en particulier de la ruralité qui
souffre d'un manque d'attractivité en
raison de l'impossibilité pour certaines
communes de proposer des terrains
constructibles pour de nouveaux
arrivants réalité d'autant plus
frustrante re lorsque nous percevons le
retour en grâce de la vie en milieu
rural depuis la crise sanitaire
or nous connaissons malheureusement les
conséquences que ces complexités en
traîne
l'une qui nous vient immédiatement à
l'esprit est celle d'une banque n'a
gagné que cela représente pour les
petites collectivités en termes de
ressources financières dans un contexte
de fragilité de la comptabilité publique
l'autre incertitude m'a été signifié par
quelques intercommunalités de mon
département de la lozère qui malgré des
efforts considérables de partage de co
construction de plans d'aménagement et
de marketing territorial seront bientôt
en dessous du seuil fatidique des 5
mille habitants mettant en péril leur
périmètre et du coup leur existence
aujourd'hui je m'adresse à vous monsieur
le ministre mais je m'adresse aussi l
ancien maire président de pci conseiller
régional conseiller général
théoriquement conscience des aspirations
de vos pairs ainsi après avoir affirmé
être ouvert à une réécriture des décrets
d'application
serait-il possible de nous préciser un
calendrier de manière à y voir plus
clair pour nos communes rurales je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est aux délices de la transition
écologique de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur christophe béchu
davet la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
première ministre madame la sénatrice
pantel
20 mille hectares
c'est le chiffre dramatique des
incendies en gironde vingt mille
hectares sur le chiffre de
l'artificialisation chaque année à
l'échelle de notre pays
et 20 mille hectares c'est le chiffre
sur lequel ici et je veux saluer ce
courage
la quasi totalité des sénateurs se sont
mis d'accord à l'unisson des députés
pour considérer qu'à l'horizon de 2050
nous devions arrêter l'artificialisation
dans notre pays parce que nous le savons
elle est responsable de la perte de la
biodiversité
elle renforce l'artificialisation les
îlots de chaleur et elle conduit là
aussi à accentuer le réchauffement
climatique
hier j'ai eu l'occasion de recevoir les
onze associations d'élus à la demande de
la première ministre pour évoquer avec
elle l'agenda territoriales et les
sujets sur lesquels nous allons
travailler de la mf à la r f en passant
par l'anem par la nel par villes et
banlieues etc toutes sans exception sont
revenus comme vous l'avait fait la
semaine dernière sur le sujet du than et
j'ai eu l'occasion de ré exprimé hier
avec elle la nécessité de ré ouvrir le
dialogue et la concertation n'ont pas
sur l'objectif qu'aucune de compte est
comme vous ne l'avez pas contesté mais
de rediscuter des modalités en l'espace
d'une semaine nous avons commencé à
poser un certain de base j'aurai
l'occasion dès la semaine prochaine je
le crois de rencontrer la présidente
prima compte tenu du sujet ce cas là
qu'elle a posés et de ce qui a été fait
par sa commission et dans la foulée
c'est bien avec l'ensemble des
associations qu'on regardera comment
maintenir un objectif intangible à 2050
et faire en sorte de répondre aux
attentes ici des territoires ruraux là
d'un territoire urbain ailleurs d'un
territoire littoral pour arriver à
concilier ces deux objectifs voilà ce
que je pouvais vous dire madame la
sénatrice pantel
quelques secondes
les mères atteintes des gestes forts et
des actes aussi merci
la parole est à notre collègue ronan
dantec pour le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoires
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues si les
engagements pris par les états lors de
la cop à glasgow sont tenus alors vers
2050 le climat se stabilisera autant de
2,3 degrés d'augmentation des
températures par rapport à la période
préindustrielle
2,3 degrés d'augmentation au niveau
mondial cela signifie une hausse des
températures d'environ 4 degrés en
france soit plus du double du
réchauffement aujourd'hui constaté dans
notre pays qui est de l'ordre de 1,8
degré
2050 2060
c'est le moment où nous couperons les
arbres les pins en particulier que nous
devons que nous allons replanter sur les
dizaines de milliers d'hectares
aujourd'hui parcourus par les flammes
ces arbres pour seront donc dans un
univers inconnu
monsieur le ministre deux questions la
première comeau avez vous prévu de
débattre avec les acteurs du secteur de
la foresterie pour que toutes les
conséquences soient tirées du
réchauffement à venir et des
catastrophes actuelles il nous faut
intégrer d'inéluctable et profond
changement des modèles d'exploitation
choix des essences diversité des
plantations débroussaillage lutte contre
les parasites tout est à remettre à plat
et les modèles économiques sont à revoir
cela ne se limite donc pas uniquement la
sécurité civile même si ce rôle reste
essentielle et nous rendons tous hommage
aux pompiers et à tous ceux qui se sont
engagés pour mener à bien cette
nécessaire mutation nous avons besoin de
la recherche publique et de nos agences
d'état ma deuxième question est donc
très simple monsieur le ministre
allez-vous mettre fin à la suppression
constante des postes à l'office national
des forêts dont la baisse de présence
sur le terrain se fait aujourd'hui
sentir en matière de prévention des
incendies et protection de
l'environnement cette hémorragie se
poursuit cette année avec 95 postes de
moi ne considère où vous pas qu au vu de
la situation actuelle un moratoire
immédiat sur la cible s'ils ont des
postes programmées serait déjà un signal
important
on vous répondre la parole et au
ministre de la transition écologique de
la cohésion des territoires monsieur
béchu
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
première me dise monsieur le sénateur
dantec
plusieurs plusieurs choses d'abord
évidemment mais je peux pas ne pas
l'évoquer sur une question sur les
incendies
2300 pompiers qui se battent aux côtés
des élus locaux des forces de l'ordre
sur chacune de ces questions le rappeler
c'est essentiel parce que le
réchauffement climatique provoque la
sécheresse des sols la vitesse avec
laquelle le feu se propage mais je tiens
à leur dire comme je lé d'hier dans 95%
des cas les départs de feu sont
d'origine humaine
et nous avons collectivement la
responsabilité de faire passer les
consignes et de rappeler la nécessité de
lutter contre cette propagation une fois
qu'on a dit ça
une fois qu'on a dit ça 1
les forêts qui sont en train de brûler
aujourd'hui elles ont pour beaucoup
d'entre elles pour tout était planté
avant les conséquences climatiques que
nous connaissons et vous poser dans
votre question la question de la
situation climatique dans laquelle nous
serons quand les forêts que nous nous
apprêtons à planter seront à maturité ya
dans ce domaine des recherches qui ont
été conduites par exemple pour faire en
sorte qu autour d'une pinède on puisse
avoir d'autres types d'essence qui sont
plantés faire en sorte que des essences
méditerranéennes plus adapté à des sols
plus sec puis s'être planté et vous avez
raison de dire qu'il faut mobiliser les
connaissances scientifiques que nous
avons sur le sujet et les moyens dont
l'état peut disposer en ce moment même
avec le ministre de l'agriculture nous
venons de faire des propositions pour la
direction générale de l'eau nf et donc
pour celui ou celle qui aux côtés du
gouvernement aura à nous faire des
propositions sur ces différents domaines
je veux ajouter une chose le nfc 25 % de
la forêt française
75 % des forêts sont des forêts privées
donc braquer les projecteurs sur ce que
nous avons éventuellement à faire par
rapport aux forêts publiques c'est une
chose mais nous ne pouvons pas oublier
le dialogue avec l'ensemble des
propriétaires de forêts privées que ce
soit en termes de couloirs de défense
incendie et de réflexion sur les
essences
la parole et à notre collègue pierre
médevielle pour le groupe les
indépendants république et directoire
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues le groupe les indépendances
associe également au soutien exprimé par
nos sapeurs pompiers qui courageusement
combattre les flammes sur notre
territoire ma question s'adresse au
ministre l'agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire nos cultures en
soif nos bêtes au chaud et n'osera
cutter souffre notre souveraineté
alimentaire est en danger face aux
dérèglements climatiques
nous ne pouvons pas les indéfiniment de
plans d'urgence en indemnisation notre
autonomie énergétique est sérieusement
remise en cause la question du
développement de solutions alternatives
urgent tout comme la préservation de nos
sur le dilemme cornélien que la grille
volta isme peut solutionner
les planètes sont alignées
production d'électricité par panneaux
photovoltaïques inclinable sur des
surfaces cultivées ou d'élevage
amélioration du revenu des agriculteurs
et des productions agricoles
artificialisation maîtriser des sols la
proposition de résolution portés par nos
collègues l'ont joué mon gars a permis
de définir cette activité la proposition
de loi que nous ont déposé avec
plusieurs sénateurs les indépendants à
l'initiative des sénateurs de cole
organise de façon réaliste le
développement nécessaire de la grille
volta isme son accompagnement et son
encadrement il est clair que
l'agriculture de rester l'activité
principale
cependant dans notre beau pays champion
de la sueur transposition et de la
réglementation aux trans certains
obstacles doivent être levés rapidement
je pense aux problèmes d'autorisation
liées au code de l'urbanisme ou à la
suppression de la pac en cas de
production d'énergie sur des surfaces
agricoles plus de quinze jours par an
monsieur le ministre ces installations
de panneaux sont démontables ne présente
aucun danger pour l'environnement et
constituent à l'heure d'un changement
climatique galopant un réel espoir pour
nos agriculteurs en matière de
protection des cultures des élevages et
d'amélioration de leurs revenus comment
comptez vous lever les obstacles et
encourager rapidement le développement
de la révolte à isme pour le bien de nos
agriculteurs et de notre souveraineté
alimentaire pour vous répondre la parole
communiste l'agriculture et souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur marc bideau celui
d'istres merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs le scène les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur médias
d'abord j'aimerais vous remercier de
votre question qui me permet de mettre
en valeur le travail qui a été fait par
le sénat par vos collègues au travers
d'une ppr et puis par vous même avec
vous d'autres vos collègues suspense aux
sénateurs de colle sur au travers d'une
ppl c'est un sujet qui est effectivement
important c'est un sujet qui portent de
nombreux espoirs le premier espoir c'est
que ça permet effectivement de lutter
contre le dérèglement est le changement
climatique en permettant de développer
les énergies renouvelables et c'est bien
la volonté qu'a le gouvernement au
travers de ces énergies mais évidemment
au travers de d'autres d'autres énergies
et donc la volonté qui est la nôtre il
est développé
deuxième élément vous l'avez dit l'idée
c'est de développer la grille voltaire
les feux
mes chers
natif de sénateurs de colle
revenu
ça permet et puis merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur mais
d'abord je voudrais vous remercier de
votre question qui me permet de mettre
en valeur le travail qui a été fait par
le sénat par vos collègues au travers
d'une ppr et puis par vous même avec
vous d'autres vos collègues suspense aux
sénateurs de colle sur au travers d'une
ppl c'est un sujet qui est effectivement
important c'est un sujet qui portent de
nombreux espoirs le premier espoir c'est
que ça permet effectivement de lutter
contre le dérèglement est le changement
climatique permettant de développer les
énergies renouvelables et c'est bien la
volonté qu'a le gouvernement au travers
de ces énergies mais évidemment au
travers de d'autres d'autres énergies et
donc la volonté qui est la nôtre il est
développé deuxième élément vous l'avez
dit l'idée c'est de développer la grille
volta isme sur une base qu'est
l'agriculture comme activité principale
ça permet à la fois d'assurer un revenu
complémentaire pour les agriculteurs ça
permet aussi de produire de l'énergie
renouvelable protéger un certain nombre
de sol et de développer un certain
nombre d'activités donc évidemment c'est
une vertu qui est importante puis
troisième sujet vous avez raison c'est
le sujet de la simplification certains
sujets sont d'ordre réglementaire
certains autres sujets sont d'ordre
législatif je voudrais souligner travail
qui sous l'autorité de la première
ministre est en train d'être menées pour
sur ces énergies voltaïque
photovoltaïque comme sur les énergies
d'autres énergies renouvelables doivent
viser sous l'autorité de la première
ministre avec agnès pannier rue nagy à
faire en sorte de simplifier les
procédures
d'un point de vue réglementaire
législatif pour que rapidement les
projets se développent il y a urgence
climatique et il ya urgence aussi pour
les agriculteurs ça permet je les dis de
sécuriser le revenu ça permet de
répondre à la question de la
souveraineté agricole ça permet de
souveraineté énergétique et ça permet de
répondre aux enjeux qui ont été évoqués
déjà dans des questions précédentes qui
sont les enjeux climatiques et donc nous
sommes à l'oeuvre pour simplifier sa
part ça relève parfois je le dis aussi
des pratiques locales et de faire en
sorte que nous puissions les uns et les
autres au travers des actions comme elle
le gouvernement donner à
l'administration les directions
nécessaire pour que les choses soient le
plus simple possible et qu'on puisse
avancer enfin sur les énergies
renouvelables merci merci
la parole est à notre collègue florence
lassarade pour le groupe véridique
madame la première ministre depuis
presque dix jours de deux gigantesques
feu ravage la gironde plus de 20 mille
hectares on l'a dit de végétation ont
été brûlés 2000 sapeurs pompiers sont
mobilisés appuyés par huit canadairs
deux avions dash je veux tout d'abord
rendre hommage ses soldats du feu ainsi
qu'aux maires des communes concernées la
gironde et le département de la france
où il a le plus de départs de feux
éteints en général actuellement la
chaleur caniculaire l'hygrométrie basse
et les vents génère des feux dynamique
d'une ampleur exceptionnelle ces
phénomènes nous les reverrons
régulièrement madame la première
ministre l'état doit rapidement adapté
son dispositif de lutte contre les
incendies aux évolutions climatiques
désormais c'est l'ensemble de la france
qui est concerné 31 % du territoire
métropolitain est concerné boisé or les
moyens de l'état dédiés au
fonctionnement desdits sont insuffisants
ne correspondent plus à la réalité
l'assiette sur laquelle se fixe le
financement des secours n'a pas évolué
depuis vingt ans alors que parallèlement
la gironde et les landes ont gagné
environ quatre cent mille habitants
d'autre part les moyens aériens ont fait
défaut au début de l' incendie en
particulier à landiras le renforcement
de la force aérienne nationale de la
sécurité civile est urgent afin qu'elles
puissent agir dès le départ du feu outre
leur nombre la localisation des
bombardiers d'eau à proximité est
primordiale face à la rupture majeure
que constitue le changement climatique
la prévention est vital l'augmentation
des départs de feux nécessitant un
besoin constant en investissement à la
charge des forestiers également pour
maintenir un bon niveau de prévention
ainsi les sylviculteurs du sud ouest
sont les seuls à payer une taxe en
france pour organiser la défense des
forêts contre les incendies cette taxe
dès fci permet entre autres de financer
par feu et réserves d'eau la situation
nous impose d'agir rapidement pour
garantir l'avenir de nos forêts
madame la première ministre je
souhaiterais savoir concrètement quels
moyens quels dispositifs le gouvernement
envisage de mettre en oeuvre pour lutter
contre les incendies
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée en charge des
collectivités territoriales m cailleux
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice florence lassarade
les feux auxquels vous faites allusion
dans votre département sont d'une
ampleur exceptionnelle au niveau
national d'ailleurs au mois de juin il y
avait déjà plus de 27 mille hectares de
forêt et 23 mai l'hectare de culture qui
ont brûlé ces feux bouleverse la vie de
nos concitoyens et je tiens à les
assurer du soutien du gouvernement
soutient également aux élus locaux
mobilisés dans ce contexte difficile
soutient enfin évidemment aux sapeurs
pompiers mobilisés sans relâche dans des
conditions d'extrême difficulté au
risque de leur vie concernant la gironde
les deux incendies de la teste de buch
et de landiras doivent encore nous
mobiliser avec force la première
priorité a été la mise à l'abri de
personnes près de trente six mille
habitants ont été évacués et nous
mobilisons des moyens considérables sur
ces deux feux ce sont près de 2000
sapeurs pompiers sapeurs sauveteurs et
deux cents forestiers qui sont engagés
les moyens aériens engagés ce jour
seront de six canadairs et deux dash
comme je l'indiquais précédemment les
moyens en renforts nationaux sont de
1222 personnes comme vous le savez aussi
le président de la république et le
ministre de l'intérieur sont en gironde
cet après midi à faire afin de faire le
point sur la situation et d'adapter les
moyens nécessaires à la lutte contre les
incendies en cours vous le voyez l'état
les collectivités et l'ensemble des
forces vives de la nation se mobilisent
pour protéger nos concitoyens et ses
territoires face à des incendies
exceptionnel
un homme lassarade quelques secondes
[Musique]
madame la ministre vous dire ma question
portait sur les actions à venir de
l'état vous me répondez sur ce qui se
passe actuellement est ce que vous avez
fait qu'est-ce qu'on fait demain
qu'est-ce que comment proportionne les
moyens aux changements climatiques
la parole est à notre collègue stéphane
pieds noirs pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre en septembre 2020 vous
déclariez notre pays n'est pas un coupe
gorge hélas en l'espace de deux mois
plusieurs meurtres à l'armé blanche vous
donne tort en mai un médecin militaire
est tué à marseille le 10 juillet un
retraité poignardé attrape le lendemain
une femme est assassinée à montpellier
le 14 juillet deux jeunes sont
mortellement blessé à metz et amiens
tout récemment évidemment nous avons
tous été extrêmement choqué par le
triple meurtre à l'armé blanche à angers
où trois jeunes hommes âgés de 16 à 20
ans issu de la communauté wallisienne
ont perdu la vie tout simplement parce
qu'il portait secours à une jeune femme
agressée sexuellement
malheureusement ces faits se multiplient
et pas seulement dans nos métropoles
sans réelle stratégie dans le déni et et
l'émotion je dirais de routine votre
gouvernement participe à la banalisation
de cette triste réalité en refusant de
nommer ces actes barbares tels qu'ils
sont et par exemple en les qualifiant de
faits divers ou par le président mac
rose de simples incivilités seul
ministre il n'est pas question ni de
stigmatiser ni de prétendre détenir une
quelconque baguette magique mais
simplement de vous interroger sur la
réponse que vous apportez aux familles
qui ne se résignent pas qu'ils
n'acceptent pas que la vie de quiconque
peut ainsi être aussi facilement fauché
dans la rue
pour vous répondre la parole
et on garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice monsieur dupont moretti vous
avez la parole monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur pieds-noirs
mesdames et messieurs d'abord vous dire
que naturellement
l'émotion rend les mots dérisoire et
pourtant ce sont des mots qu'il convient
que je prononce pour répondre à votre
question tellement légitime
à présent j'ai 400 anonymes et les
familles se sont réunies sur le parvis
de l'hôtel de ville
ils ont tous exprimé l'idée qu' aucune
récupération politique ne devait
intervenir et d'ailleurs je ne vous fais
en aucune façon ce procès
vous n'êtes pas l'extrême-droite et nous
le savons
alors quelques chiffres tout aussi
dérisoires que les mots pour affirmer
que depuis de nombreuses années les
meurtres commis dans ce pays sont à peu
près stables mais pour autant cela ne
nous amène pas au fatalisme vous
l'entendez quelles sont les réponses que
nous essayons d'apporter
eh bien d'abord l'augmentation des
moyens et vous les avez voté davantage
de policiers davantage de magistrats
davantage de greffiers sur le terrain de
la prévention parle de jeunes et de
jeunes auteurs en l'occurrence le code
de justice pénale des mineurs qui permet
désormais va aller beaucoup plus vite de
rendre une réponse plus rapide vous avez
voté ce texte à nos côtés et puis enfin
naturellement la sévérité de la réponse
pénale quelles réponses peut-on apporter
aux familles une réponse judiciaire elle
sera rendue par nos compatriotes puisque
c'est vraisemblablement une cour
d'assises qui aura à dire ce qu'elle
doit dire en la matière mais je profite
de cette question pour tordre le cou à
des idées fausses qui circulent de façon
récurrente sachez mais vous le savez
bien sûr qu'en l'an 2000 le taux des
peines fermes était de 28% il est
aujourd'hui de prendre 6 % le quantum
moyens en 2000 était de 6 mois ferme il
est aujourd'hui de 9
virgule six mois ce qui fait de notre
pays l'un des plus sévères d'europe je
note encore qu'entre 2021 et 2022 la
durée moyenne d'emprisonnement augmenté
de 11% et j'ai tenu pour tendre le cou à
ces idées fausses qui font le lit de
l'extrême droite j'ai tenu à créer au
ministère de la justice un observatoire
mensuel des peines d'emprisonnement je
tient naturellement tous ces chiffres et
toutes les réponses à votre disposition
merci monsieur le sénateur de m'avoir
permis d'exprimer ces quelques mots dont
je sais et je le redis qu'il ressent
face à cette émotion totalement
dérisoire
monsieur pieds noirs
[Applaudissements]
c'est le ministre vous le savez la
sécurité est la première des libertés
que l'état doit à ses citoyens dans
notre société constate en pleine
déliquescence
le règlement de compte avec l'opinel
aujourd'hui monnaie courante
l'indifférence par rapport à la mort de
l'autre est aussi monnaie courante dans
cette société il vous faudra beaucoup de
courage et beaucoup de conviction pour
restaurer l'autorité républicaine à tous
les niveaux de l'école jusqu'à
l'institution judiciaire et nous
comptons sur vous pour le faire merci la
parole avec notre collègue denis bouad
pour le groupe socialiste et que le juge
du
procès la présidente madame la première
ministre l'homme dabistes dames la
première liste nous sommes à plus de la
moitié des questions qui concernent ces
malheureuses et se dire incendies de ces
derniers mois de ces dernières semaines
j'aimerais bien que vous puissiez
répandant la question n'est pas du tout
pour les 8 depuis le début du mois de
juin à ce qui concerne le mans
département et avec une alim une gravité
accuse dernières semaines la france est
en proie à de terribles incendies bien
entendu j'ai dépensé pour ce département
de la gironde mon collègue hervé gillé a
eu l'occasion de parler de cette
situation dramatique comme lui je
voudrais d'abord rendre hommage à
l'engagement remarquable nos sapeurs
pompiers et de l'ensemble des acteurs
sur le terrain dans les prochaines
années le risque d sorte d'interdît sera
plus étendu dans le temps mais également
dans l'espace
la prévisionniste font état d'une
augmentation de 80% des surfaces brûlées
d'ici 2050
malheureusement l'été que nous
traversons fait que renforcer le poids
des alertes scientifiques dans ce
contexte alors que ce sont des communes
et les départements qui financent les 10
comment pouvez-vous justifier que ces
derniers soient contraints de payer le
malus écologique lorsqu'ils achètent des
véhicules indispensable à leur
intervention
de la même manière comment pouvez-vous
justifier que les dix s'acquitte de la
tei ccpp alors que d'autres missions
régaliennes de l'état comme l'armée en
sont exonérés alors bien sûr comme un
changement climatique suppose des
politiques ambitieuses pour réduire nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre à ce
titre chaque hectare de furie de forêt
qui brûle impacte notre capacité à
stocker du carbone mais il est également
bon de rappeler que la lutte contre le
changement climatique nécessite aussi
des investissements massifs pour
accompagner adaptation nos territoires
sur ce dernier point alors que le risque
d'un incendie de plus en plus important
le volontariat de nos sapeurs pompiers
qui se sent rénumérés qu'à 9 euros de
l'heure ne pourra à lui seul compte
issus eux ils constituent une réponse
sur le long terme ma question est donc
simplement de la première ministre alors
que les territoires sont différentes
touchés par les aléas climatiques
que ce soit les incendies que ce soit
les inondations les canicules en visez
vous de recourir à la solidarité
nationale pour le financement des 10 et
le renforcement des moyens aériens qui
je dois le dire tomber les appartements
sont des moyens quand même qu'ils sont
relativement ancien merci
pour vos réponses la parole est à la
ministre délégué chargé des
collectivités territoriales
alain caillau
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur denis bouad la crise que nous
connaissons d'ampleur exceptionnelle
mobilise fortement les moyens de lutte
contre les incendies j'étais d'ailleurs
moi-même dans le gard il y a une dizaine
de jours aux côtés des élus quant à feu
extrême s'est déclaré dans les cévennes
ces conditions conduisent à une
mobilisation d'ampleur que j'ai eu
l'occasion de rappeler d'ailleurs en
réponse au sénateur pascal martin et à
la sénatrice florence lassarade en seul
gironde les moyens humains et matériels
sont considérables et les renforts
nationaux marque la solidarité de tout
le territoire pour lutter contre ces
feux dans ce contexte vous appeler
l'attention du gouvernement sur la
question légitime du financement des ce
10 c'est dans ce but que la loi du 25
novembre dernier portant sur notre
modèle de sécurité civile dite loi
matras prévoit qu'un rapport soit remis
par le gouvernement au parlement d'ici
au 1er janvier prochain il portera sur
le financement des services
départementaux et territoriaux
d'incendié et de secours il devra
notamment premièrement dressé
l'évolution des recettes et dépenses de
ces établissements publics avec des
prévisions du court au long terme
deuxièmement faire l'analyse des
critères de calcul des dotations et
contributions versées à ces
établissements publics et évaluer leur
pertinence
troisièmement déterminer les besoins
associés aux différentes prestations
versées aux sapeurs pompiers
professionnels et volontaires pour
l'ensemble des financeurs et détaillé
les conséquences budgétaires propres aux
services départementaux d'incendié et de
secours enfin préciser les conditions
dans lesquelles par dérogation le ca du
cices peut décider de financer
l'allocation de vétérance versées aux
sapeurs pompiers volontaires relevant
d'accords communale ou intercommunale
voilà mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs ce rapport nous permettra de
poser les bases de la réflexion que vous
appelez de vos voeux
merci la parole est à notre collègue
daniel grémillet pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président madame la première
ministre mais c'est un mini chers
collègues
la nationalisation annoncée d'edf aussi
tonitruante soit elle ne répond pas aux
difficultés du groupe la première
difficulté financière c'est le mur
d'investissements rêver d'une dette de
43 milliards d'euros le groupe a perdu
18 milliard avec la corrosion sous
contrainte 10 milliards avec leurs
éléments de la reine en parallèle edf
doit s'engager dans des investissements
colossaux 65 milliard pour le grand
carénage 90 milliard pour les opm le
deuxième enjeu est juridique c'est
l'articulation avec le droit européen
les concessions hydroélectriques sont
sous le coup d'un différend vieux de 20
ans avec la commission européenne
quarantaine sont arrivés à échéance et
que dire du principe du coût marginal
qui lie le prix de l'électricité à celui
du gaz c'est un désavantage pour notre
mix
le dernier problème et stratégique c'est
l'absence de cap ne sont toujours pas
quelle est la politique énergétique du
gouvernement il souhaite une
nationalisation une relance du nucléaire
aujourd'hui mais il a arrêté la centrale
de fessenheim en 2020 et le projet
astrid en 2019 quant aux concessions
hydroélectriques on a évoqué tout et son
contraire d'un côté on parler
d'ouverture de recoupement de quasi
régie que d'indécision que deux
revirements que de retard aussi ma
question est simple au delà de
l'association comment comptez-vous
résoudre des difficultés d'edf qui met
en péril notre souveraineté
on vous répondre
la parole est au ministre de l'économie
des finances et de la soul funky
industrielles numériques monsieur bruno
le maire
ce président
messieurs les sénateurs
d'abord je vais vous dire que je suis
toujours très sensible à l'accueil
chaleureux que me réserve le sénatrice
et les sénateurs
et je voudrais remercier le sénateur gré
milliers de sa question qui porte sur
des enjeux stratégiques pour notre
nation le président de la république a
décidé la nationalisation d'edf qui doit
nous permettre
d'accélérer le renforcement de
l'indépendance énergétique de la nation
française qui est chacun le voit bien au
regard des enjeux liés à la guerre en
ukraine à l'augmentation des prix
énergétiques au manque d'énergie
l'enjeu le plus important pour notre
économie et pour notre nation
aujourd'hui ensuite quelle est la
feuille de route qui va être donné au
groupe pour les années qui viennent la
première urgence c'est produire plus
c'est retrouver une capacité de
production d'électricité qui soit à la
hauteur du groupe chacun le voit bien
aujourd'hui nous sommes sous les 3 100
térawattheures de production c'est
insuffisant la priorité absolue c'est la
remise en route des réacteurs qui ont
été mis à l'arrêt pour produire
davantage
la deuxième urgence c'est de réaliser le
programme de six réacteurs nucléaires
si nous vous rétaux nucléaire côté
annoncé par le président de la
république au creusot c'est sans doute
le défi industriel le plus important qu
edf est devant elle pour les années qui
viennent faudra le faire vite il faudra
le faire bien c'est des instructions qui
ont été passées par la première ministre
et que nous mettrons en oeuvre avec
agnès pannier rue nash et la troisième
urgence énergétique vous avez
parfaitement raison de le souligner
c'est de mettre fin à l'absurdité du
modèle européen dans lequel le prix de
l'énergie décarbonée est aligné sur le
prix des énergies fossiles
nous voulons des résultats rapides sur
ce sujet la présidente de l'union
européenne a commencé à bouger la
commissaire mariann vesta guerre
également nous voulons réformer le
marché européen de l'énergie quant à
notre stratégie énergétique a est très
simple en trois mots ont été rappelés
par andré public au creusot plus de
sobriété plus énergies renouvelables et
une confiance totale dans l'énergie
nucléaire
sûre rêviez
le 13 janvier 2021 ici au sénat la
musique de l'énergie indiqué s'agissant
d'edf je cite il y aura un texte
spécifique sur ce sujet et d'ajouter si
cette négociation ouvre le champ des
possibles jamais elle ne se substituera
à la voix des élus de la nation ni à
l'indispensable débat parlementaire sur
l'avenir d'edf avant toute réforme mes
chers collègues edf
ces 75 6 années d'histoire n'oublions
pas qu'on a légiféré en 1946 pour la
nationalisation d'edf n'oublions pas
qu'on a légiféré en 2004 et en 2010 pour
sa modernisation et aujourd'hui on ne
légifère répu c'est purement scandaleux
je voudrais dire simplement la stratégie
de notre souveraineté énergétique ne
peut se résumer à une simple au pea sur
edf merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue catherine
morin desailly pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la première milices
madame le gouvernement veut supprimer la
redevance principale ressource pour nos
entreprises de l'audiovisuel public pour
des dizaines de milliers d'emplois
directs et indirects
on parle ici de 3 milliards d'euros
cette mesure est malheureusement
aujourd'hui déconnectée de toute
réflexion sur le devenir d'un secteur en
plein bouleversement madame bachelot
ayant choisi d'enterrer le débat
nécessaire de la réforme audiovisuelle
engagée par son prédécesseur
tout comme elle est déconnectée du
contexte lourd et à certains de nos
finances publiques cette suppression se
joue maintenant dans une certaine
opacité puisqu'on vient de découvrir le
rapport de l'iac igf commandé en octobre
par votre prédécesseur rapport qui nous
arrive en plus hélas tronquée cette
mesure redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux
français tel est l'argument pourtant on
parle de lui substituer une part de la
tva elle payée par tout le monde sans
distinction de ressources rappelons
qu'aujourd'hui 5 millions de foyers
soient exonérés de la redevance
sérieusement compte tenu des enjeux
multiples et complexes ne serait-il pas
sage comme le réclame tout le secteur
très inquiet de reporter cette décision
qui selon le rapport n'est pas sans
risques juridiques et politiques
pour vous répondre la parole
la ministre de la culture madame
abdulmalik
même la ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice mme morin dessailly le
deuxième public c'est le premier média
des français le premier financeur de la
création aussi nous y sommes très
attachés nous comptons bien le préserver
et l'accompagner dans ses mutations et
dans ses réformes avec la fin de la
redevance c'est le prélèvement qui
pèsent aujourd'hui sur les français 23
millions d'entre eux que nous supprimons
pas son financement et encore moins son
indépendance le sénat d'ailleurs le
reconnaît lui même dans le rapport de
roger karoutchi et jean-raymond hugonnet
la redevance et je cite à bout de
souffle en effet elle est adossée à une
taxe d'habitation qui va disparaître et
elle est adossée à la possession d'un
poste de télévision alors que de plus en
plus de français regardent aujourd'hui
la télévision sur d'autres écrans par
ailleurs vous le savez cette redevance
ne suffit pas puisque chaque année
l'état rajoute environ 600 millions
d'euros pour couvrir le budget de
l'audiotel public donc le lien direct à
la dotation de l'état a toujours existé
l'enjeu c'est évidemment de maintenir
l'indépendance et de maintenir le
financement notre audiovisuel public
nous sommes bien d'accord je pense sur
ce principe fondamental et jeudi
maintenir parce que l'indépendance elles
existent pleinement aujourd'hui les
dirigeants ne sont pas nommés par le
gouvernement mais par l'art comme le
régulateur indépendant qui donne aussi
son avis sur les contrats les contrats
d'objectifs et de moyens tout comme vous
tout comme les commissions
parlementaires et surtout le
gouvernement n'a aucun moyen
d'interférer dans les grilles dans les
programmes donc vraiment l'indépendance
éditoriale et bien réel alors oui
aujourd'hui le gouvernement a proposé un
nouveau mode de financement pour
l'audiovisuel public avec plusieurs
garanties
la compensation à l'euro près le
versement de l'intégralité des
ressources en début d'année pour éviter
une régulation en cours d'année et une
visibilité pluriannuelle accrue du
financement des amendements étaient
déposées à l'assemblée sur cet article
nous allons discuter ensemble dans
l'hémicycle nous aurons ce débat en tout
cas je veux vous redire que la ligne du
gouvernement est très clair redonner du
pouvoir d'achat aux français tout en
assurant un autre de vielles public son
financement dans le respect total du
pluralisme et de l'indépendance des
médias merci à la mort de seuil est
forcément madame la ministre vous voulez
être rassurante et on vous en remercie
mais il n'y a pas urgence à se
précipiter dans cette réforme quand on
sait qu'on ne dispose pas de toutes les
études d'impact sur le sujet toutes les
garanties aujourd'hui d'ailleurs ne sont
pas apporté les garanties à
l'indépendance de nos médias publics il
existe aussi des textes européens
exigeaient une jurisprudence en la
matière et des garanties également sur
la prévisibilité et la dynamique des
ressources aujourd'hui proposé c'est ce
que disent les présidents des
entreprises auditionné la semaine
dernière à l'assemblée nationale et puis
selon le scénario choisi mes chers
collègues on sait qu'il y aura un impact
aussi sur le budget de l'état est de la
dette publique dont on nous dit la côte
d'alerté est atteinte alors notre groupe
refuse donc la précipitation et le
bricolage de dernière minute au détour
d'un plfr au contraire il souhaite
participer un travail collectif sérieux
éclairé de l'ensemble des études et que
soit redonner du sens politique à cette
réforme et il appelle comme le rapport à
une concertation je cite permettant de
fédérer l'ensemble des entités affectés
par la réforme offrant une sortie par le
haut ni plus ni moins aux parlementaires
responsable et constructif nous
souhaitons ce rapport et ce travail de
fond je vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue laurent
duplomb pour le groupe est républicain
madame la première ministre après mon
rapport sénatorial de 2019 qui alertait
déjà sur le déclin de la production
agricole française favorise en même
temps l'entrée toujours plus grande de
produits agricoles importés qui ne
respectent pas nos normes après
l'épisode de koh vide qui nous a fait
prendre conscience de notre dépendance à
des produits faits à l'autre bout du
monde est dans le même temps nous à
faire recoudre découvrir l'intérêt
majeur d'une alimentation produite en
france après l'entrée en guerre de la
russie contre l'ukraine faisant flambée
des prix jamais égalés les matières
premières agricoles ce qui nous rappelle
l'intérêt majeur de disposer d'une
agriculture forte et protégés après nous
avoir fait croire que vous aviez
récemment compris tout cela en nous
vantant par exemple les bienfaits des
clauses miroir en rebaptisant le
ministère de l'agriculture en ministère
de la souveraineté alimentaire comment
en ayant dit et vu tout cela
pouvez-vous ne pas vous opposé aux
accords de libre échange entre l'union
européenne et la nouvelle zélande
on vous répondre
la parole est aux milices de l'europe et
des affaires étrangères
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur du plomb la
commission européenne est parvenue en
effet dans le cadre de ses compétences
en matière commerciale à conclure le 30
juin un accord de commerce avec la
nouvelle zélande nous sommes en train de
l'évaluer en détail leurs premières
analyses je souhaite vous dire qu'il
s'agit d'un bon accord et je vais vous
dire pourquoi
d'abord parce qu'il va faciliter l'accès
au marché néo zélandais et renforcer nos
positions dans nos secteurs exportateurs
en matière de biens comme de services
ainsi que notre accès au marché public
néo-zélandais
ensuite parce qu'il s'agit de l'accord
le plus ambitieux en matière de
développement durable que l'union
européenne ait jamais conclues sur le
modèle qui nous conduit désormais à
intégrer des clauses environnementales
et sociales dans les accords de nouvelle
génération je ne doute pas que vous y
soyez sensible sur le sénateur il
prévoit des sanctions commerciales en
particulier en cas de violation des
principaux engagements en la matière et
enfin c'est un bon accord parce qu'ils
protègent n'offre nos filières agricoles
sensible et parce qu'il soutiendra nos
exportations agricoles et
agroalimentaires notamment en protégeant
plus de 200 indications géographiques
comme le compte et au le jambon de
bayonne par exemple et ceci n'est pas
anecdotique pour nos territoires loin de
là
cet accord sera signé et ratifié par
l'union européenne dans le cadre de ses
compétences également après approbation
du parlement européen avec olivier bayle
je m'engage évidemment à venir vous le
présenter plus en détail une fois que
cette approbation aura été acquise je
vous remercie monsieur du plot
j'en appelle à un sursaut national
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça madame la
première ministre que je vous avais posé
la question et que j'aurai véritablement
espérer que vous y répondiez
arrêtons tant qu'il est encore temps ces
injonctions contradictoires nous ne
pouvons pas rajouter sans cesse des
critiques des contraintes des normes qui
tue la compétitivité de notre
agriculture et la livre et en même temps
à une concurrence déloyale vous ne
pouvez pas continuer d'interdire de plus
en plus de molécules en france et fermé
les yeux sur les produits issus d'une
agriculture néo zélandaise qui utilisent
encore de l'atrazine interdite chez nous
depuis 2003 madame la première ministre
madame la première ministre réveillez
vous il aurait mieux valu pour répondre
à la question plutôt que votre ministre
car la france agricole sont morts entre
sécheresse abandon des surfaces
cultivées des capitalisations des
troupeaux partout en france si vous
n'arrêtez pas le massacre vous
connaîtrez le même sort qu'avec
l'électricité le black out alimentaire
alors quand comprendrez-vous enfin la
leçon
[Applaudissements]
et c'est donc
la parole
un autre collègue franck montaugé pour
le groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président et cher collègue
monsieur le ministre
mes gars feu puis diluviennes
dévastatrice sécheresse toujours plus
précoce et plus forte gelée répéter
grêlons gros comme des boules de
pétanque autant d'illustrations des
effets du dérèglement climatique dont le
giec nous avait avertis de rapports en
rapport la transition de civilisation
que nous devons opérer parce que c'est
de cela qu'il s'agit en réalité repose
sur la production et l'usagé d'énergies
décarbonées dans cette bataille la
france possède un atout maître edf dont
la propriété sera bientôt entièrement
public mais une opé a ne fait pas un
projet industriel après avoir passé cinq
ans à ne prendre aucune décision à la
hauteur des enjeux le gouvernement est
resté muet sur le rôle qu'il entend
faire jouer à cette entreprise dans le
contexte extrêmement difficile que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre quel est votre projet
industriel social et environnemental
pour edf avez-vous s'est grandement
souhaitable renoncer au découpage de
l'entreprise comment financez-vous les
investissements d'edf nécessaire au
grand carénage aux énergies
renouvelables et au nucléaire existant
est programmée ainsi qu'au réseau
comment préserver vous le caractère
public du parc de production hydraulique
une au pea va exclure de fait les
citoyens et le parlement de ce débat
national pour donner suite aux
intentions qu'on croyait nouvelles de
dialogue que le gouvernement affichait
qu'il ya quelques jours à peine
allez-vous passer par une loi spécifique
c'est ce que nous vous demandons pour
vous répondre la parole et au ministre
des finances la souveraineté
industrielle et numériques monsieur le
maire vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur montaugé d'avant je voudrais
dire à quel point je partage convenait
de dire sur l'énergie nucléaire
à tous ceux qui nous ont expliqué
pendant des années que l'on pouvait
gagner le combat climatique sont le
nucléaire la réponse est définitive nous
ne pouvons pas gagner la bataille du
climat sans reconstruire des capacités
nucléaires je rappelle que le président
de la république est le premier à avoir
engagé la réalisation de six nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires
que notre majorité est la première à
avoir mis sur pied une université des
métiers du nucléaire pour redonner ses
lettres de noblesse à l'activité de
production d'électricité nucléaire et
que d'autres majorités la première avant
dégagé dans franche 2030 des moyens de
financement aussi important pour
réfléchir aux réacteurs de petite et de
moyenne taille pour être en pointe des
technologies sur le nucléaire oui nous
croyons au nucléaire est oui nous
continuerons à le défendre et le
développer
s'agissant d'edf et du financement de
notre opération ces 9 7 milliards
d'euros qui seront financés sur un
compte d'affectation spécial du trésor
je pense qu'il n'y a pas de meilleure
illustration de notre détermination à
soutenir eu d edf et à voir l'état aux
côtés d'edf et de ses salariés pour les
années qui viennent nous avons cours des
dernières années
recapitalisée edf engagé sa
nationalisation nous nous sommes donc
donner les meilleurs moyens de permettre
à ce grand service public de l'énergie
de réussir et nous apporterons les
moyens nécessaires aux investissements
55 milliards d'euros environ pour les
sous de nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires
enfin sur la structure d'edf jeu
laissait planer aucune ambiguïté nous
avions un projet de réforme qui
d'ailleurs nous pousse n'a jamais
consisté à découper edf mais ne revenons
pas sur le passé cette réforme
correspondait un temps où il y avait
moins de tension de difficultés
d'approvisionnement nucléaire la réforme
hercules est caduc et de ne reviendrons
pas dessus qu'il n'y ait pas d'ambiguïté
nous voulons marquer avec un programme
in his à nouveau départ pour edf cette
nationalisation est la première étape à
la direction maintenant avec l'état de
définir ses priorités
monsieur montaugé
ministre ça répond pas tout à fait aux
questions que je posais de
tergiversations un atermoiement la
france viennent de perdre en réalité
cinq ans pour répondre à ses missions de
production edf doit rester un groupe
intégré intégré sous statut
d'établissement public à caractère
industriel et commercial pour l'intérêt
général national ou sept ans kiev ne
soit pas entravée dans son développement
nous sommes donc pour la suppression de
la reine et cela doit aller de pair pour
la restructuration des tarifs de
l'électricité sur la base du coût
marginal complet à long terme le prix de
l'électricité ne doit plus dépendre des
marchés de gros et aujourd'hui de celui
du gaz naturel n'avaient pas tout à fait
répondu aux questions monsieur monsieur
le ministre j'espère malgré tout que
nous aurons un débat ici au parlement
sur ce sujet extrêmement important
madame la premier ministre opine de la
tête je le note et donc je prends
rendez-vous nous prenons rendez vous
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant d'autres
collègues damien regnard pour le groupe
verizon 8 heures
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères mes chers collègues c'est par
un décret en catimini au coeur de l'été
2018 le 3 août précisément que le poison
a commencé lentement à se répandre ce
poison c'est celui de la république des
copains qui permet un romancier
contemplateur du couple présidentiel de
nommer philippe besson au sud général à
los angeles au lieu d'une personne dont
c'est tout simplement le métier de
représenter la france et nos
compatriotes à l'étranger
ce poison madame la ministre n'a depuis
eu de cesse de miner notre diplomatie
qui pâtit d'une absence de vision de
consultation et de concertation
depuis le début de l'année je me suis
rendu dans près de 30 pays soit autant
de rencontres avec nos postes
diplomatiques
partout la même inquiétude monte oui
l'inquiétude monte face à une réforme à
la fois injuste et incompréhensible
vous avez pris la décision de supprimer
le corps diplomatique
après cinq ans d'une politique
d'improvisation constante vous avez
décidé qu'il était désormais possible de
s'improviser aussi diplomate or on ne
s'improvise pas diplomate
c'est une vocation une carrière que l'on
construit au fil des expériences oui
l'inquiétude monte face au manque de
considération pour nos diplomates dont
plusieurs dizaines à attendre encore
aujourd'hui leur affectation pour la
rentrée lorsque vous agissez ainsi c'est
l'image de la france qui est abîmée et
la voix de la france qui est affaibli
oui la france peut se targuer de
bénéficier d'un solide réseau qui a su
s'ouvrir largement et se diversifier
depuis plusieurs années oui la france
est riche de ce corps diplomatique de
son savoir faire et de son expertise
respecté partout dans le monde et si ce
corps doit évoluer
cela doit se faire dans l'écouté le
respect et la concertation sans esprit
partisan et certainement pas avec un
décret pris discrètement entre les deux
tours de l'élection présidentielle
madame la ministre avez vous conscience
de l'image désastreuse que cette réforme
injuste renvoi en france comme à
l'étranger que comptez vous faire r pour
permettre à notre diplomatie de
poursuivre sa mission de manière
professionnelle et sereine pour vous
répondre la parole de la milice de
l'europe que les affaires étrangères
madame colonna
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur régnard merci de
votre question monsieur le sénateur et
en particulier merci d'avoir rendu
hommage aux agents du quai d'orsay qui
le méritent un agent qui tous statuts
confondus en le sens du service public
chevillée au corps effectivement je vous
remercie de l'avoir rappelé leur
mobilisation au service de ton patriotes
et de notre pays ait connue et elle a
été apprécié tout particulièrement lors
de crises récentes pandémies
afghanistan ukraine pour ne citer que
quelques exemples
lorsqu'il s'est agit de protéger nos
compatriotes
mais nous avons en effet tous relevé
qu'une partie des agents a fait grève le
2 juin dernier dans un ministère dont je
dirais qu'il n'est pas coutumier du fait
ma responsabilité c'est donc d'en tenir
compte et je vais agir dans trois
directions
d'abord mettre en oeuvre la réforme de
la haute fonction publique réforme de la
haute fonction publique qui ne concerne
pas que le quai d'orsay en l'expliquant
et en expliquant mieux en montrant les
opportunités qu'elles présentent en
termes de mobilité interministérielle en
consolidant les garanties obtenues par
mon prédécesseur jean yves le drian et
en démontrant aussi que quelques
contre-vérités n'ont plus lieu de courir
la mise en extinction des cordes
ministre plénipotentiaire et des
conseillers des affaires étrangères ne
signifie pas monsieur le sénateur
l'extinction ni des métiers ni dé
carrière diplomatique le quai d'orsay
continuera à recruter les meilleurs
profils et les diplomates pourront y
dérouler des carrières sur la durée
deuxièmement examiner la question des
missions et des moyens moyens
budgétaires et moyens en emplois dans un
contexte international où l'émission ont
cessé de croître climat santé biens
publics mondiaux protection des français
et enfin
c'est une concertation sur l'avenir de
notre diplomatie pour réfléchir et
réfléchir avec vous aussi si vous le
voulez bien l'outil diplomatique dont
l'état et dont les français ont besoin
ce sera un exercice important nous
aurons besoin de vous de votre regard de
vos idées de votre exigence pour cette
concertation que je souhaite inclusive
mais aussi positive je vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue jean
claude anglars pour le groupe l'est
républicain à vous
merci merci monsieur le président
madame la première ministre monsieur le
ministre délégué chargé de l'industrie
sarr collègues le 12 juillet le
président de la république s'est
félicité d'avoir créé 120 sites
industriels et d'avoir mis fin à la
désindustrialisation de la france
cependant la conclusion inverse s'impose
en effet le directeur de m h industries
dont la volonté doit être saluée vient
de renoncer à déposer une offre de
reprise de l'usiné de l'ex sam à viviez
decazeville en aveyron faute
d'engagement de renault et de
sécurisation du financement
les 333 salariés licenciés et leurs
familles les habitants et leurs élus se
battent depuis des mois contre le
démantèlement de l'outil de production
et la fuite des savoir-faire de la
métallurgie aveyronnaise le bassin de
decazeville par la volonté des
collectivités locales porte en effet un
projet industriel réel pour l'avenir de
son territoire un mach industrie
proposer la reprise du site avec de
vraies perspectives de diversification
afin de ne plus dépendre du client
unique renault alors pourquoi l'état
n'est-il pas au rendez vous hier
monsieur le ministre vous avez déclaré
que le repreneur s'est retiré à cause
d'une commande insuffisante du client
historique et d'une relation
client-fournisseur dégradé votre
déclaration en tant que représentant de
l'état actionnaire de renault n'est pas
acceptable l'état serait-il complice
d'une quelconque sanction
évidemment vous allez me répondre que
l'équation économique et peu viable que
l'état est votre prédécesseur
comment on peut assurer un suivi
constant et que les anciens salariés
sont accompagnés dans leur retour à
l'emploi ou alors au classement monsieur
le ministre ne nous dit pas que les
perspectives de réindustralisation sont
bonnes en particulier l'aviron tout un
bassin d'emplois souffrent et la mecanic
vallée est fragilisé alors monsieur le
ministre que dites-vous aux élus locaux
qui sont désemparés
quelles sont vos solutions pour assurer
la transition et l'innovation
industrielle des fonderie dans les
territoires ruraux
faux répond la parole est aux délégués
on cherche de l'industrie monsieur
roland lescure vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur anglais remercie
pour votre question vous le savez
puisque nous avons échangé dès lundi
après midi au téléphone j'ai scruté
appelé tous les élus la présidente de
région le président département les
parlementaires dont vous et votre
collègue à la marque consacrée concernés
pardon par cette situation l'abandon du
projet je le regrette autant que vous
mais je comprends malheureusement j'ai
eu l'occasion d'échanger beaucoup avec
le repreneur avant sa décision après y
compris pour essayer d'ailleurs de le
convaincre de la maintenir vous l'avez
dit la relation dégradée avec le client
historique à participer à sa décision
mais aussi et surtout la conjoncture
internationale dégradé le
renchérissement des matières premières
qui rendait l'opération très risqué sans
doute trop risqué pour sam mais aussi
pour son entreprise à lui est la
dernière chose que nous souhaitions je
pense vous et moi c'est qu'une en une
heure une opération de ce type puisse
fragiliser deux entreprises au lieu
d'une alors vous l'avez dit vous avez
fait une partie de ma réponse et dont je
vais faire vite pour autant les salariés
aujourd'hui sont notre priorité nous
souhaitons les accompagne et vous le
savez plus de la moitié d'entre eux
aujourd'hui en une solution on va en
trouver une pour chacun d'entre eux y
compris pour les quelques-uns pour
lesquels la retraite est sans doute la
solution qu eux-mêmes privilégient et
c'est un sujet important sur lequel avec
mon collègue olivier du soft nous avons
déjà commencé à travailler et pour
autant désolé je vais me permettre de
vous contredire je pense que la
réindustrialisation du bassin elle est
possible elle est souhaitable et que
nous allons y arrivées ensemble on a des
personnes qui sont extrêmement qualifiés
compris d'ailleurs les salariés de sam
on a des entrepreneurs qui sont
volontaires on a des élus locaux j'ai eu
l'occasion de parler avec le maire de
decazeville le maire de viviez le maire
de rodez nous pouvons le faire et je le
ferai comme je lé fais à l'occasion de
cette nouvelle décevante lundi en
collaboration avec l'ensemble des
personnes qui souhaitent vraiment y
contribuer notamment les élus vous
disiez monsieur le sénateur il ya
quelques mois nous avons besoin d'un
sursaut national pour réindustrialiser
réindustrialiser part dans les
territoires je sais que vous faites
partie des personnes qui souhaitent
contribuer à ce sursaut je suis prêt à
travailler avec vous merci merci nous en
avons terminé avec les questions au
gouvernement nos prochaines questions
d'actualité auront lieu le mercredi 27
juillet à 15 heures je vais suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour le
projet de loi maintenant provisoirement
un dispositif de veille et de sécurité
sanitaire en matière de lutte contre le
comique 19 la séance est suspendue